monday edition of pft pm it's supposed
to be a slow day in a slow week it's the
monday after the fourth of july weekend
but plenty of things happening in the
nfl and the biggest news came out of
nowhere monday afternoon the new
contract between the kansas city chiefs
and quarterback patrick mahomes as
reported by adam schefter of espn the
deal runs
through 2031.
that is one of the longest term deals i
have ever seen
i have a lot of questions about why
patrick mahomes would commit for that
long think about what can happen
in a decade when you're talking about a
player
on a given team the team could be sold
who knows you can't rule that out you
will definitely well i don't want to say
definitely but most likely have a new
coach by 2031
most likely a new gm by 2031 a lot of
things will be different by then
do you want to have no exit strategy do
you want to have no off ramp do you want
to be tied to the team beyond the point
where the team is tied to you and
remember the team is only tied to you as
it relates to the years that are fully
guaranteed
after that you are tied to the team for
as long as the team wants to keep you
and once the guaranteed money is
exhausted in any contract in the nfl the
years after that are basically one year
at a time options held by the team and
as long as they think it's a good deal
for them to keep paying you what they're
supposed to pay you they'll keep paying
you that amount
if they think it's too much that's when
they rip it up that's why in this case
it's way too long for patrick mahomes to
commit unless and this is a big unless
and this is something that a lot of
people i suspect are trying to chase
right now and maybe by the time you see
this video we'll have an answer so i
apologize in advance if this video
quickly becomes obsolete by the news
crush that is going to happen in the
aftermath of the news of this new
contract but the only thing
that causes the mahomes deal to make
sense for that long is if he's the first
player in league history to get a
commitment that he will earn a
percentage of the salary cap because the
cap is going to keep going up and up and
up and i know what you're thinking next
year it may not well that's why what you
do is you pick a certain salary
and you have a percentage
of the salary cap in each year whichever
one is greater is what the player will
get that's what patrick mahomes needs to
have if he's going to be committed for
that long i i'd like to think that he
got that kind of a commitment before he
made that kind of a commitment but we'll
see
if if not
it's going to be in my mind a very very
disappointing outcome because whatever
the numbers are and they're going to be
huge right 10-year extension 400 million
contract gigantic 40 million a year
that's been the number we've all been
pegging but
40 million a year isn't going to be that
big of a number five years from now
seven years from now that was the
problem with deals that the eagles used
to do when joe banner was the team
president
the eagles would identify
their talented core players early and
sign them to ultra long-term deals and
inevitably those players would end up
pissed off about the terms of those
deals and the eagles are like hey hey
hey you took the guaranteed money you
took the signing bonus you signed the
contract to deal with the deal now i
don't know if the chiefs would do that
with patrick mahomes and patreon doesn't
seem like the type who's going to get
agitated that way but
there's a chance he left a lot on the
table if he didn't get a commitment that
he'll get 16 17 18 of the salary cap
whatever the cap is in any given year
that's the key detail and here's hoping
for his sake that that is what will
happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports